devenu l'anpn qui exprime sa grande
inquiétude et assure le cren de son
soutien indéfectible face aux mouvements
de troupes russes près de ses frontières
kiev accuse moscou de masse et des
soldats au nord et à l'est le chef de la
diplomatie européenne s'entretiendra
avec son homologue ukrainien est les 27
ministres des affaires étrangères des
pays de l'ue lors d'une réunion au cours
du mois d'avril
ce matin le porte parole du kremlin à
dmitri peskov s'est exprimé on retrouve
à moscou notre correspondant en train de
l'hérault bonjour antoine comment réagit
mouscou faux déclaration de l'union
européenne et bien le porte parole du
kremlin a été très clair la russie n'est
une menace pour personne notamment
l'ukraine et reste simplement attentive
à sa propre sécurité
en attendant dans le donbass le
cessez-le-feu en vigueur toute la
deuxième moitié de 2020 n'est plus
respecté le conflit fait de nouveau des
victimes l'ukraine dénombre une
vingtaine de soldats tués depuis le
début de l'année mais de l'autre côté
aussi il y à des pertes en particulier
parmi les civils ainsi en république
populaire de donetsk
un enfant de cinq ans a été tué écoutez
chaque mort surtout s'il s'agit d'un
enfant est une tragédie
c'est une tragédie tout cela est une
conséquence grade une situation qui n'a
pas été réglé et plus encore
la conséquence de l' escalade des
tensions sur la ligne de contact
malheureusement les accords ne sont pas
respectées les responsabilités assumées
auparavant notamment par la partie
ukrainienne ne sont plus respectés de
fait les échanges de tirs peu contrôlées
sont entamées et ce sont des commandant
des opérations des forces armées
ukrainiennes qui prennent les décisions
sur le terrain sans obtenir une
autorisation de leurs supérieurs
militaires
tout cela aggrave la situation l'attend
encore plus on en parle beaucoup
actuellement
vous le savez mais malheureusement à
l'heure actuelle nous ne voyons aucun
effort effectifs de la part de kiev
une critique qui en effet de nombreux
titres de presse ont commenté des
mouvements de troupes en russie à
proximité de la frontière ukrainienne
on a aussi entendu jo by dell ou encore
vous l'avez évoqué le chef de la
diplomatie européenne apporté leur
soutien sans faille à l'ukraine mais on
entend rarement la position des
autorités locales du donbass qui sont
pourtant en première ligne et les
principaux concernés par cette hausse
des tensions
je vous propose donc d'écouter comment
son vécu les événements du point de vue
du président de la république
autoproclamée de donetsk l'ukraine
continue de sa beauté ces négociations
et ne permet pas de faire en sorte
qu'elle se déroule comme prévu et pour
parler au sein de tous les groupes sont
bloqués par conséquent nous ne voyons
pas de résultats bien entendu cela
confirme que le crâne attise les
tensions notamment sur le plan
médiatique en nous accusant moulin et la
russie de préparer quelque chose alors
qu'en réalité ce sont les forces armées
ukrainiennes et les décideurs de kiev
qui sont à blâmer
au jour de ce crime odieux complète des
chaînes youtube
on en revient donc toujours la question
de l'application des accords de minsk
seuls textes signés et reconnu par
l'ukraine et la russie alors que cela
fait maintenant sept ans que ce conflit
a commencé et rien n'incite à
l'optimisme qui a fait adopter des
sanctions contre des entreprises russes
sanction qui devrait engendrer des
mesures réciproques de la part de moscou
et aucune réunion internationale au
format normandie par exemple n'est
prévue pour le moment
merci beaucoup antoine antoine claireaux
depuis moscou